[Music]
Russian President Vladimir Putin is
known for his bizarre photo ops in the
West bees seem crazy they're the kind of
thing that we turn into internet memes
they make great animated gifs there are
entire tumblers devoted just to photos
of shirtless Putin doing things action
figures showing him riding bears and
doing other crazy things but where we in
the US and other countries see this as
kind of the crazy antics of an egomaniac
in Russia they actually have a very
important political purpose that's an
image that looks like it should be
airbrushed onto the side of a van in a
New Jersey rest area so in Russia
Putin's image is crafted very carefully
to make him seem like a public figure
that is both powerful and loveable so
that is what it says when Putin is kind
of interacting with animals or children
but he also is very careful in these
photos to stage them so that he's
powerful he's riding the horse kind of
surveying the land around him often they
show him as if he's kind of stepped into
somebody else's profession for a day and
had incredible success in it on one
occasion he appeared as a dentist he
famously had this photo up in the Black
Sea where he was shown emerging from the
water carrying two ancient Greek
amphorae
which are these incredible
archaeological finds and the initial
story was that he just happened to have
been swimming and discovered them but it
quickly came out that in fact they had
been planted there for him to discover
so the message from all of these is that
he is this incredibly impressive
individual but it also has a more simple
and direct message which is don't worry
Russia Putin is healthy and everything
is going to be fine
the truth is that power in Russia is
centralized with Putin to an incredible
degree there's no clear successor in
place it's not at all clear what the
government would look like without him
and that makes it pretty scary for
people to contemplate what would happen
if Putin were suddenly to become
seriously ill they also reassure
Russians that Putin is healthy and
strong he is trying to kind of live up
to this Russian ideal of the real man
the person who is strong and macho and
impressive and powerful a lot of these
photos are also designed to show how
impressive Russia is when he's hunting
that's a reminder of its kind of wealth
of wildlife and natural resources no one
is as popular as Putin nobody is as
recognizable there isn't anyone who has
that kind of populist appeal and when he
shows that he has these high levels of
popularity that's a way of showing the
elites you know I've got this you don't
need to worry that the country is going
to slip from my grasp and it's also a
way of reminding them that there's no
one other than Putin there is no other
figure in Russia who has the same level
of elite support and also popular
support
[Music]
these photos might seem weird and crazy
to us but they actually tell us a lot
about Putin's political strategy and
where he stands both with the Russian
public and with Russian elites
[Music]
never to be
[Music]